in the West we have a vague sense that
poetry is good for our souls makes us
sensitive and wiser yet we don't always
really know how this should work poetry
has a hard time finding its way into our
lives in any practical sense in the East
however some poets like the 17th century
Buddhist monk and poet Matsuo Basho knew
precisely what effect their poetry was
meant to produce it was a medium
designed to guide us to wisdom and calm
as these terms are defined in Zen
Buddhist philosophy Basia was born in
1644 in Newaygo in the eager province of
Japan as a child he became a servant of
the nobleman Toto Yoshi Dada who taught
him to compose poems in the haiku style
traditionally haikus contained three
parts two images and a concluding line
which helps juxtapose them old pond our
frog leaps in water sound this is the
best-known haiku in Japanese literature
and it's called old pond by basher
himself it's all deceptively simple and
when one's in the right generous frame
of mind
very beautiful after your sheet otter
died in 1666 Basha left home and
wandered for many years before moving to
the city of Edo where he became famous
and widely published however Basha grew
melancholy an often shunned company and
so until his death in 1694 he alternated
between travelling widely on foot and
living in a small hut on the outskirts
of the city Basha was an exceptional
poet but he didn't believe in the modern
idea of art for art's sake instead he
hoped that his poetry would bring his
readers into special mental states
valued in Zen Buddhism his poetry
reflects to the most important Zen
ideals Wabi and sabi Webby means
satisfaction with simplicity in
austerity while savvy means an
appreciation of the imperfect it was
nature more than anything else that was
thought to foster webby and savvy and
it's therefore unsurprisingly one of
bashers most frequent topics take this
spring scene which appears to ask so
little of the world and is attune to an
appreciation of the everyday first
cherry budding by peach blossoms Bosch
shows poetry is an enormous shocking
simplicity at the level of theme there
are no analyses of politics or love
triangles or family dramas the point is
to remind readers
that what really matters is to be able
to be content with our own company to
appreciate the moment we're in and to be
attuned to the very simplest things life
has to offer like the changing of the
seasons the sound of our neighbors
laughing across the street the little
surprises we encounter each day take
this gem violets how precious on a
mountain path Basha also used natural
scenes to remind his readers that
flowers weather and other natural
elements are like our own lives
ever-changing and fleeting time and the
changing of weathers and scenes need to
be attended to as harbingers of our own
deaths
this transience of life may sometimes be
heartbreaking but it's also what makes
every moment valuable yellow rose petals
Thunder a waterfall Basho like to paint
as well as write and many of his work
still exists usually with the related
haikus written alongside them this
painting by Basha depicts this very
haiku in literature Basha valued Kurumi
lightness he wanted it to seem as if
children had written it he abhorred
pretension and elaboration as he told
his disciples in my view a good poem is
one in which the form of the verse and
the joining of its two parts seem light
as a shallow river flowing over its
sandy bed the ultimate goal of this
lightness was to allow readers to escape
the burdens of the self one's own petty
particularity and circumstances in order
to experience unity with the world
beyond basher believed that poetry could
at its best allow one to feel a brief
sensation of merging with the natural
world one may become through language
the leaf the waters the Stars leading
one to an enlightened frame of mind
known as muga loss of awareness of one's
self we can see bashers concept of muga
or self forgetting a work in the way he
invites us almost to inhabit his
subjects even if they are some rather
unpredictable the lips of salted bream
in a world full of social media profiles
and crafted resumes it might seem odd to
want to escape our individuality
after all we carefully groom ourselves
to stand out from the rest of the world
Basha reminds us that muga or self
forgetting is valuable because it allows
us to break free from the incessant
thrum of desire and incompleteness which
otherwise haunts all human lives
Basho knew what some of this was like
he's
for long periods from deep melancholy
after his house burnt down after his
mother died and sometimes for no reason
at all sometimes he didn't feel like
seeing any of his friends he spent long
periods of time traveling the dangerous
back roads of the Japanese countryside
with little more than writing supplies
and he spent some truly unglamorous
nights fleas and lice biting awake all
night
a horse pissing close to my ear yet muga
freed Basho and it can also free us from
the tyranny of glum moments of
individual circumstance the poems are
valuable not because they're beautiful
though they are this too but because
they can serve as a catalyst for some of
the most important states of the soul
his poetry constantly invites us to
appreciate what we have and to see how
infinitesimal and unimportant our
personal difficulties are in the vast
scheme of the universe they remind both
the writer and the reader that
contentment relies on knowing how to
derive pleasure from simplicity and how
to escape even if only for a while the
tyranny of being ourselves
you